I want to tell a real story is
absolutely true about ten years ago my
wife and I came to Atlanta for the first
time we go right from the airport to the
hotel we go right to the bar cuz that's
what I do I get to the bar I sit down
the waiter brings over an appletini with
an umbrella in it and he says from the
gentleman over there Charles Barkley
laughing his head off at me you sent her
the most embarrassing appletini and I
had to drink it you listen you know you
love that I love it he just looked like
the appletini time thank you very much
you do I did well hey well you look good
by the way you look very good and you're
one to talk because I read everywhere
that your manscaping like crazy these
days you listen they give me a hard time
I have to get my nails done and I get my
eyebrows waxed no wait a minute stop I
have heard of guys getting their their
nails done you get your eyebrows waxed
you know I thought I got some issues
going on like this stuff going on in my
ears now you know you saying this stuff
in your ear connects to the eyebrows
apparently apparently like sometimes
I'll look and I'll see like it looks
like fingers come in little hairs
everywhere like manscaping you like to
you have to take care of business
everywhere what are we talking about
here you know actually I haven't done
anything else I get a pedicure but
that's it okay all right all right are
you interested in exploring other areas
not yet okay not yet hang for it you
know as I've gotten older hair has his
own agenda okay let's leave it at that
let's talk about your future there's
talk that you might want to be a GM is
that right I might be interested in
doing that in the future maybe even the
near future you know what I'm gonna be a
Jim you know I don't want to outstay my
welcome when I took this job I said I
was only gonna do it for four years and
this is 14 years I love my job a lot of
people I work for but I think you you
should only do this thing a certain
period of time and then move on and move
on now you're talking maybe about going
out west you know I want it listen I
need sunshine I'm a delicate flower
don't let this rugged exterior fool you
I'm really I need sunshine you have been
quite critical of Michael Jordan oh did
you get a good job I love I love Michael
he's one of my great friends but you
know he you love Michael you say doesn't
go to you also you go after him for his
look sometimes you say well no people
tell me he's good-looking first of all
he's not good-looking he's not he's not
missing listen he error every man who
got 500 million dollars is good-looking
Susy if he was a plumber people wouldn't
be saying he'd be good ain't no way okay
all right all right is every man got
three or four hundred million dollars is
good-looking okay all right this is good
to know you said in an interview it's
long and you've said this many times
it's long been your dream to call a game
with ESPN's legendary sportscaster Nick
by tau is that right it doesn't want to
Besant one of my goals to work with dick
I think he's been great for basketball
and I would love to do a college game
with him since we expenses now the since
we're doing the tournament
that's one because he's fantastic at
what he does it's unbelievable to me
that two iconic sports casters like
yourselves have not worked together yet
but we've been on different teams but I
was really gonna listen first of all he
spoke to me in college and told me that
made me really feel good about myself
and I never forgot that
but if he's a he's a legend I'm just
getting started but he is a legend and
and I would be honored for me to work
with it all right well what we do here
at this show is make dreams come true
ladies and gentlemen legendary ESPN
college basketball analyst dick Vitalis
here let's have a come out
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen after after this
commercial break for the first time ever
these two legends will call the action
together during an exciting live
sporting event right here on this stage
don't go anywhere
[Applause]